Where has he been?
When will he return?
The prophecy foretells of the coming of a dark age...   (oh boy).
An age when he will be missing, but the prophecy foretells one more thing....
Look now closely.
Closely into your own heart.
Into your own mind.
Into your own soul.
And there he is. (BACK FROM JAPAN AYY)
There, he has always been.
Waiting.
Forever.
With you.
Inside you. (um)
A part of you. (errrm)
Always.
*amazing entrance by papa pewds*
*laughs in Swedish*
I'm back
Oh.
He was just in the closet the whole time. (we can now officially say he came out of the closet)
Hello everyone, it's me!
Thank you for welcoming me back.
I've been away a couple of days. (A WHOLE DAMN WEEK)
It's been, it's been good, had a good time...
YAY LWIAY
That's right, we're going to look at more memes together. (relationship goals)
Probably they're all going to be outdated because uh
It's been a WEEK (that was such a painful week.)
Memes uh, if any memes in this year surpasses one week lifetime, that would be great
That would just be great (okay connoisseur)
We gonna go through the GREEN SCREEN COMPEtiTION
Let's 👏🏻 begin 👏🏻👏🏼👏🏽👏🏾👏🏿
Somebody toucha ma sPaGhEtT *ear rape*
Well, what did I say (laughs)
Should I just go back?
I'll go back, I need another time.
Hi, I'm Renata Bliss and I'm your freestyle dance teacher
*poods at the club yes daddy*
Come on
*pewds making weird noises*
Guys
I think there's a dead body dere!
It'll be over soon
You don't wanna mess with ME! (come at me bro)
Oh classic fighting great
*epic fight ensues*
Wow
*KnOcKoUt*
(pewds laughs)
DAMN that was amazing
Wow
I could barely tell it was edited
Damn, so good waaw
(woman yelling) (axe chopping)
Hello, nice to meet you, wanna be friends?
I have an army of 60 million subscribers
(stab stab)
AGHHHHHHHHHGHHHHHHHHHH
Beautiful, it's just great.
Hey, oh my GOD
That's a battlecry
You don't wanna mess with me
I have an army of 60 million subscribers 😉
Look at my muscles 😍
Frah frah fraaah
What
So famous
Oh I want a full version! (same bro)
That was so good
OH MY GOD.
Someone spent hours on this, God damn. God bless you. Matt Jones, you earn this sub. God damn (let us have a moment of silence for our one, our only Matt Jones.)
Fol- follow me
Alright it's coming out of my ass
I run this way to (pants)
Oh it's a big one.
*death scream*
*this is the new pr0n*
It's a baebae
I love it so much.
You're gonna be such a great mother.
I'm gonna call him Jacksepticeye. (i ship it)
Beautiful
*good old "bike" meme*
Somebody toucha
I don't know, I don't know what to say Greg
*how pewds gained success*
Hey come on, come on
Have I told you about this chair btw?
Have I- I don't know if I introduced you my chair _| _/ __
It's 399 and it can...
Do a lot of things, it can do a lot of things, okay?
Woah
What made you decide to join the paratroopers?
I wanna fight you and steal all of your subscribers
JESUS
It's an easy company
It's time to stop
I'm just like where am I
(paratrooper pewds) I will fight you
Heyy
HAAAAAAAHHHHH
I'm proud to serve each and every one of you
do you kno da wei (repeats)
Great great yes great.
Does anybody here kno da wei.
Hey guys I found DA WEI, follow me!
This man knows DA WEI, show me DA WEI.
That's right, in ya go. (what am i watching)
Imposta, you do not know da wei
Oh yeah, you think you so good huh
Yeah? You think you're tough? but CAN YOU DO THIS AAARGH (_| _/ __)
Wait, I'm running low on batteries
*ear rape warning*
Pewds: SPAGHETTTTTTTT Jack: JESUS CHRIST OH NO
OH NO
Aww poor Jack, did I scare you?
Did I scare you little Jackie boy?
Jackie boy got scared
By a video game
oooo it's so scared
I would never get scared by a video game because I'm a real man
My testosterone levels ‾ ; your testosterone levels _
Hello, nice to meet you, wanna be friends?
Hell no
Aww come on Piques
Oh yeah? but CAN YOU DO THIS?
*vine gunshot sound*
*more generic vine effects*
THREE NINETY NAINE
CAN YOU JUST BUY MY CHAIR PLEASE
IT'S 399
Oh you think you're so good huh
You think you're so good now huh
You think you're tough?
Huh? You think you're something
BUT CAN YOU DO DIS
*LIT MIXTAPE*
YES!
THREE NINETY NINE AND YOUR DEPRESSION WILL BE CURED
OF COURSE.
YES I am using.
mental illness to sell my chair
What
What, that's not
That's not okay?!
I love the movie edits
*pewds laughing*
I know where this is going
(echo) MEME 👏🏻 REVIEW 👏🏻
MEME 👏🏻 REVIEW 👏🏻
Cute, that was cute, very cute
"I hope Julia is very happy with her choice..." [Brazilian meme]
Holy cow this one got 11,000 uploads?
You don't wanna mess with me
Cuz imma fight you
What that's not true!
I have an army of 60M subscribers
Woah
They say that I'm faster than lightning itself
There's a dead body right there
Oh yeah, this was great
Dude: Alexa, what do you do?
I go through funny pictures, and go haha
That you guys make, you guys make pictures
Irrelevent dude: Awesome
Irrelevent dude: Alexa, play rock music
♪ HEJ MONIKA HEY PÅ DIG MONIKA ♪ (had it on repeat for 4 hours, just now spelling lyrics correctly.)
Dude: Alexa stop
WhAt
Girl: Alexa, what time is it?
It's time for BONUS MEME✨ (papa bless)
Dude: It uses far-field technology, so it can hear you from anywhere in the room
Irrelevent dude: So it can just hear you anywhere?
Dude: Yes, well everyone can hear you anyway (ok uh that a lil creepy ;-;)
ABSOLUTE MADLAD!!!
Girl: Alexa, add wrapping paper to the shopping list
399, that's a great price! (I'm PISSING)
Girl: Alexa, how many teaspoons are in a tablespoon?
18 MIN-
No, no no OKAY
That was the green screen submissions (holololol)
Good job *laughs*
Give yourself a round of applause 👏👏
We're back with the daily uploads (good bc if you didnt upload soon, i was going to fart out my heart. And pop my right lung.)
I had a great time when I was away, but I'm very happy to be back :)
Keep making videos
Did you miss me (yes 😭😭)
Leave a like, and if you didn't, leave a like
Also, be sure to leave a like (i just made 3 different accounts and liked, and now im wasting my time writing this CC that no one will read. Rip.)
Can we get this video on trending? (COME ON SQUAD FAM)
And that's it for me for now
See you tomorrow with a new video (OH YES DADDY)
And as always
I'm going to go back
Where I sleep ;)
Have a great one, have a great time everybody
And remember
Leave a like
If you're depressed (Felix, you have cured my depression.)
Thank you
*i wanna sleep in that closet*
*evolution of le pewds*
😍
(why are you still here lolol bye im gonna read some smut)
👊